سين يا رب تكونوا بخير واقدر اشوفكم واقدر
احضنك يا
رب والله احنا كطاقم طبي احنا دورنا نعالج
خصوصا حالات الخدج نعتني بهم لانه بكون
عندهم نقص اكسجين فيش عندهم تغذيه خصوصا
الطفلتين هدول كانوا يعانوا جرثومه في
الدم كحاله صحيه الامور نوعا ما
احسن بناتك هم اه اه بناتي انا ولدتهم في
مستشفى صحابه حمن مستشفى الصحابه صار في
اخلاء ودم على كمال عدوان ومن كم عدوان
برض في مستشفى كمال عدوان صار في اخلاء
وحولهم على الجنوب انا ما كنتش اعرف اي
حاجه عن طول مهمه الجنوب لحدنا ابن عمتي
كان يدور عليهم وقاهم
يعني قدامي والله نفسي اشوف احكي
معهم حبايبي يا ماما كيف حالكم يا عمري يا
رب تكونوا بخير اقدر اشوفكم واقدر احضنك
يا رب
حبايبي ط شي صعب هذا انه انت تكون داير
بالك على اثنين مش موجودين اهلهم شي يعني
انساني بعتبرهم امانه عندي موجوده انه انا
بدي ادير بالي عليهم يعني اكثر من الاطفال
الثانيين لانهم مش موجودين الاب ولا الام
لانه في حواجز وفي دبابات على الطريق ما
بقدروا يجوا من الشمال للجنوب
لعنا
فانا يعني تعر انا ام انا جد بدي اعرف
اخبارهم بدي اعرف علومهم بدي اعرف علوم
اودي حرمه ولد اللي مسكين بالقيصري وغرز
طلعت
وغرز وما قدرت حتى تتعالج الاثنين صحتهم
كويس هي الطفل الثاني بتتحرك وسمعك هي
بسمعها صوته يا
عمري يا رب اش على جري يا رب
العالمين لحظه واحده وجدنا نفسنا انه فعلا
احنا في تحدي تحدي انه احنا لازم نقبل
اطفال كل القطاع كان من ضمن الاطفال اللي
عننا ال 31 طفل الطفل اللي هو المجهول وجد
على شجره زي ما استلمنا من اطباء الشفاء
والطاقم تبع الشفاء هيها عننا الطفله
مجهوله الهويه اجت من
الشفاء لقيناها جنب مسجد الصبره في
استهداف مسجد الصبره وها تقريبا عننا
شهرين موجوده من بدايه العدوان الاسرائيلي
على غزه سميناها ملاك مش مش قادرين انه
يعني نضلنا نحكي بالقاب مجهوله الهويه
مجهوله
[موسيقى]
الهويه